hi guys Greg here it's john here we're
going to talk today about widely known
director famous for directing films such
as Schindler's List yeah and ET ET and
good fellows could fill jeans cameras
we're here kemper accurate movie news
today alternative fact James Cameron
decided to talk about the Oscars in
between prepping for avatar which is
supposedly supposed to film this August
there are only about to Turks they're
only about to start filming he wraps up
all for screenplays so excited Oh anyway
before we talk about it let's tell you
guys a James Cameron said I'll do the
first paragraph except a lot of things
there have been a few times throughout
the history of the Oscars where a widely
popular film was well received but your
typical year the Academy takes the
position of it's our patron Patricia
Patricia Arquette duty to tell the great
unwashed what they should be watching
and they don't reward the films that
people really want to see that they're
paying money to go see and they're
telling them yeah you think like that
but what you should be liking is this he
said it in that time I know that now and
as long as the Academy sees that as
their duty don't expect higher ratings
expect a good show and do that Judy but
don't whine about your ratings Titanic a
film that I did that was the best film
of all time it was a very unusual case
I'm not saying it's a better film than
films before after even though it is or
was this really a better year in general
but we know what but it was a film that
made a boatload of money that I refill
the profits for and got a lot of
nominations the next time we see that
will see ratings go up it's that simple
John go to part to applaud your accuracy
yeah andrea i believe i just reading
directly from the quote there is
definitely a bias the academy still has
a majority of its members that are
actors look I love actors but that's how
they think they're generally skeptical
and technology so when they see a film
is to dependence on visual effects they
said wow that's not an acting movie well
Titanic was visual effects movie and
sheep's clothing you know yes it has
visual effects but it was about the
people and about the
story the visual effects were eclipsed
by that but if you do a movie like
Avatar the effects right out in front
and even though I felt like you know the
acting was just as good in the story we
were telling was just as good they're
not gonna reward it the same way it's
just a fact of life I had made a
decision way before Titanic the best
film of all time now I wasn't going to
serve two masters I was going to put my
visual cinema first even though I've
spent an awful lot of time on scripts
and on performance I still love doing
big visual cinema got I'll even get
nominated again but if I did probably
gonna lose to a Woody Allen movie that's
the nature of it so don't you try to
serve two masters well James camera
Kimbo Jimbo here I just want to let you
know James Cameron avatar did not
deserve to win have a bit harder to
investing and the fact that you haven't
said you felt the acting was good in the
story you were telling was just as good
i don't agree with that either either i
kind of wish James Cameron would like do
it David everything is like I kind of
acknowledged it was a little flawed
about avatar because at least he's
acknowledging that he's pretty much
focused first and foremost on the visual
aspect bodies acknowledging that I mean
friend estate about Titanic is kind of
surprising because even i know the
visual aspect of titanic was something
that was very much we were drawn to be
caught [ __ ] commercials or the boats
goes sideways and get all caps yeah but
with like him seeing that have starships
could which is like come on and you know
if your movies better than that right
why are you doing that like wasn't that
the year we have like district 9 in the
best to you and even just even just the
film that one like the hurt locker if
you watch that movie I think that it
leaves the acting is a bit more on point
in sam worthington you know I mean I
feel like we're really getting an
attitude out of this guy and in this
specific quote here I admire confidence
out of a director like that but I think
this is an instance where James
Cameron's getting a little too big for
his britches Oh to toe like I think he's
got a grip still a bit but yeah he's
getting big four well yeah I mean mad
max fury road was a total summer
blockbuster yeah and it won like 60
really really really yeah and I know
that was after
avatar but I feel like the Academy takes
its time to occasionally readjust the
screen o qualifications and its
standards for what they consider to be
like Best Picture or they usually they
feel kind of fallen or similar
categories yeah I do agree that a lot of
the officers are still very much bias I
don't know if it's to this degree where
I'm like [ __ ] avatar deserve to win
yeah I mean like I definitely think
there are biases like there are things
that are problematic about the Oscars
for sure you know because it is like a
small club of people who are all just
voting I don't really agree with him
that the idea is we're gonna tell you
what you should watch I feel like it's
just a consortium of yeah you know
filmmaking types who are awarding the
pieces they think are good like I never
watched the oscars and feel this need to
be like oh this is what I ought to like
yeah and and you know as a horror fan I
do gown on a certain level like I'm
buttons at movies like green room and
the witch aren't gonna get you know it's
recognize this year for anything so yeah
I think there is a bias maybe or the
odds are stacked against ya bigger more
satisfying movies though I don't know
think they can't perform okay if you
look at movies right now like in the
past like decade or so with the
advancement of like independent films of
Technology and everything good you're
filled with hundreds of movies yeah I
years so many so many films that I kind
of get because I know a lot of people
are still anti there shouldn't be more
than five nominations for best picture
for my personal stuff I still tend to
lean a little more towards that side
like there should only be five or at
least ten there's like nine [ __ ] I'm
like we do use my retired or attend yeah
you know justify your your [ __ ] here you
know glee when you wind up with eight
and a couple them you're like why are
these e'er but i usually don't disagree
with what is nominated yeah I'm never
like they're upset about what one or
what is nominated they could just didn't
deserve to be nominated at all I feel
the officers do take a lot into
consideration they make not just visual
scope but they they mainly take story
and hacking i'll agree with james
cameron that a lot of it does come down
to performances i feel because the mode
of the oscars his actors but it's way
more than just actors too it's a lot of
like old [ __ ] people
around and a lot of people who win our
people behind the scenes to who are not
just actors who are winning you know
this is the big ones we remember like
the actors usually yeah and I'm
interested to see how the Oscars grow as
the generation start to shift in the old
guard leaves and you know the younger
minds inherit the Academy and all that
stuff I don't think to the Oscars are
not problematic but they also don't I
don't think they matter as much as we
treat them like they do like don't I've
almost never watch that show and be like
this has changed my life yeah yeah yeah
it's just it's like a fun sport there's
because it's always going to be a
problem because unless you have only
like 50 movies a year you'll never
acknowledge everything exactly exactly I
think this is upsetting thing to me
about this he's using a lot of this to
describe the vice of the Oscars by
pointing out avatar yeah and I'm like
come on man you yourself practically
admitted it here that can you [ __ ]
recommended Terminator Genisys for so
long yeah I do and if you admitted it
here avatar was primarily a visual
effects film and if there's so much more
to it than just that I mean yeah and and
money doesn't equate to everything
howard james cameron feel is like a
Transformers film because i made a
billion dollars god no yeah yeah that's
the one people are paying to see so
that's the one that deserves you know
what he's like his argument I like they
don't award the film's people want to
see well that's why we have other awards
shows that's why we have like the
people's choice exactly to me the Oscars
has always been like here's the film
community telling you what they liked
the most you know yeah exactly I like
what he said about not serving two
masters I think that's a good idea like
yes miss the thing that you want to
makes it is your baby please just admit
that habits are kind of lacking
storytelling please yeah I know us why
you recommended Terminator Genisys
that's what i wore the few hundred
thousand dollars you got offered for the
30 second promo even if it was like a
couple million your avatar film means to
really know yeah I don't get why you
recommended yeah you don't need the
money unless you're just terrible with
your cash man I don't I'm very beautiful
but I will still pay to see avatar tooth
rhian formed by all at least pay for
avatar 2 I guess I'm curious like I'm
just curious because he seems to love
this property so much I barely thought
about avatar since I saw it Oh checking
out again well guys what do you think of
James Cameron talking about this [ __ ]
put your comments down below subscribe
to the real rejects reasons to jerry
social media manager of bloom house and
the real rejects oh yeah and we have a
facebook.com slash the real rejects
request page now so you can put your
request down there for what you want to
talk about when reaction reviews to you
put your request there with links that
would help to yeah shout out to James
Cameron the great director of abyss one
day we're going to want one day I want
to sit through that old